el médico puede aconsejar una
intervención quirúrgica para tratar
determinados trastornos de la atm si los
tratamientos no quirúrgicos no funcionan
después de un tiempo es importante saber
que los procedimientos quirúrgicos para
los trastornos de la atm son
controvertidos y deben evitarse si es
posible los procedimientos quirúrgicos
para los trastornos de la atm incluyen
los siguientes are troceen tesis
artroscopia are trotó mia o reemplazo de
la articulación
durante la atroz en tesis el cirujano
introducirá dos agujas en la
articulación la enjuagar a con un
líquido estéril para lavar el tejido
cicatricial y mejorar el movimiento
durante la artroscopia el cirujano
realizará una o varias aberturas
pequeñas en la piel delante de la oreja
se introducirá una pequeña herramienta
con una diminuta cámara en la
articulación para permitir al cirujano
ver la causa de los problemas el
cirujano puede utilizar la misma
herramienta para reparar la articulación
a través de las pequeñas aberturas
algunos problemas requieren que se abra
la articulación
durante la artroscopía el cirujano hará
una incisión delante de la oreja
una vez abierta la articulación el
cirujano podrá arreglar problemas como
un disco que esté fuera de su sitio
a veces la atm puede estar lo
suficientemente dañada como para tener
que reemplazarla durante este
procedimiento la articulación se
reemplazará por un dispositivo
artificial llamado prótesis las partes
de la prótesis son el componente de la
fosa y el componente mandibular
durante una intervención de reemplazo
articular el cirujano realizará una
incisión sobre la articulación y otra
bajo la mandíbula
después de preparar la articulación para
la prótesis el componente de la fosa se
colocará en su lugar con tornillos
a continuación el cirujano fijará el
componente mandibular al hueso del
maxilar inferior con tornillos
alrededor de la nueva articulación se
colocará grasa del vientre o de las
nalgas esto ayudará a evitar la
formación de tejido cicatricial y exceso
de hueso al final del procedimiento las
incisiones se cerraran con puntos de
sutura
es importante que hable de los riesgos
con su proveedor de atención médica
porque una intervención quirúrgica de la
atm suele ser irreversible podría
empeorar su problema y no reducir el
dolor
si tiene preguntas sobre los
tratamientos para los trastornos de la
atm o tiene un dolor en la atm que no
desaparece habla con su proveedor de
atención médica